ROMAN NURIK: Hello and
welcome once again to
Android Design in Action.
Today's episode is actually a
slightly different format.
This is a prerecorded version of
the show, because we have a
special guest here today.
So before we introduce
everybody, my name is Roman
Nurik I'm your host.
We're also joined by Nick
Butcher over in London.
NICK BUTCHER: Hello.
ROMAN NURIK: And like we
mentioned before, we're joined
today by a special guest.
ALEX FAABORG: Hi, I'm Alex
Faaborg, a designer on the
Android team.
Very happy to be here.
ROMAN NURIK: And today we're
going to be talking about
notifications and the design
process and Alex will be
leading the way with
a bunch of slides.
Before we jump in,
Alex, do you want
to introduce yourself?
Say a few words about
what you're doing?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah,
sure thing.
So I work on the Android
system and platforms.
So things like notifications,
obviously the topic of this
show today, intents, launcher,
just sort of the base
interface of the OS itself.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
And do you focus primarily on
interaction design, visual
design, or where would
you say you have a
specialty in any of those?
ALEX FAABORG: Primarily
interaction.
Some visual direction, but
mostly interactive designer.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome, OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Hopefully a lot
of people are seeing the
excellent Google I/O
presentation that you gave
with Christian Robertson as well
on Design for Engineers.
I've particularly enjoyed that,
and have cribbed a lot
of your lines that you use in
many of my presentations.
ALEX FAABORG: Thanks.
To plug my other video.
Keep watching this.
And then when you're done
watching this, be sure to
check out Advanced Design for
Engineering from I/O 2012.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, so with that
should we jump into the slides
about notifications?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah,
definitely.
So notifications and view.
Let's dive into this.
The first thing I want to talk
about is the psychology
concept of flow.
The flows, basically it's hard
to describe-- you can read the
Wikipedia article about
it, if that helps.
But it's best to just
think about times
you've experienced it.
So it's when everything fades
away and you're just really
focused intently on something
you're creating.
So like if you're a musician,
you're not thinking about the
musical instrument that
you're playing.
Or even playing video games,
you don't think about the
controller that you're
holding.
The controller just sort
of fades away.
And you also get into this state
with computing a lot,
where you're engaged in
what you're doing.
Or with a mobile device,
you're out
in the world engaged.
And what can destroy flow
is interruptions.
And notifications are kind of
fundamentally interruptive.
So flow's a really good state
for people to be in.
And it's a little bit dangerous
to be constantly
pulling them out of that.
The main problem there is that
they're just not going to be
as effective.
So flow was proposed by the
psychologist Csikszentmihalyi,
and it's characterized by this
complete absorption of what
you're doing.
ROMAN NURIK: Is this kind
of like a feeling
of I'm in the zone?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, it's like
exactly what it is.
So I think what's important to
think about is the user's
attention stream is this
precious resource that needs
to be protected.
Especially on tablets, these
larger format devices, they're
possibly reading a book.
Although, effectively, a lot
of full screen apps are now
going in lights-out mode where
people aren't going to be as
visually interrupted.
ROMAN NURIK: It's almost
like a feeling of
immersiveness, right?
Like, you're immersed in the
content of what you're doing.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
So I think it's really important
to think about.
Assuming the user is immersed,
is it worthwhile to interrupt
them with the notification that
your application's about
to generate?
Sometimes it is.
So to use a developer analogy,
basically what you're doing is
you're blocking the
user thread--
like, literally the
user's brain.
Like you are blocking their
cognitive flow momentarily to
deliver your notification.
So do you want to block
that thread?
So three rules for creating
notification.
The first one is does it
involve another person?
So like a real time chat,
is there someone or
a Hangout or something?
Is there someone sitting
there waiting for you?
So you need to get that person's
attention because
this other person's actually
waiting on them.
ROMAN NURIK: It's kind of like
is another thread waiting on
you to complete.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, exactly.
Another very important
human thread is
like waiting for you.
So that's the first one.
Is it time sensitive?
You'd block something on your
calendar, that event's going
to end, you need to get to it.
And that's one of the reasons
why you'd want to deliver an
notification.
And then finally, is it
something that the user
specifically requested?
So like an alarm doesn't
involve another person.
It is time sensitive and it's
something the user set.
So is this something
that the user set?
Please remind me at this moment,
or if this happens.
Then, of course, it's totally
OK to barge in.
A lot of notifications on
Android don't follow these
three rules.
And that's not good.
We would love to see
applications put more thought
and care and planning into
if a notification's
worthwhile or not.
And we have new capabilities.
Especially with the low priority
notifications, where
your application can generate
notification and
put it in the shade.
So a user goes in there,
they see it.
But it's not something that's
going to cause the phone to
vibrate and buzz, or the
LED to illuminate.
So it's not going to actively
grab the user's attention.
It's just going to be there
in case they go and check.
So that notification's kind
of along for the ride when
another notification does
actually ping you.
Then they can consume
all of them by
clustering them together.
ROMAN NURIK: And we've
talked about this a
little bit on the show.
I think we've called them
opportunistic notifications.
If you have the opportunity, if
the user's already in the
process of checking what's going
on, then give them that
information.
An example of this would be
Google Now's Weather.
I think the default weather is
a low priority notification,
so it only shows up if
you already expanded
the notation chain.
ALEX FAABORG: Right.
So actually, all of Google Now's
notifications are low
priority, with the exception
of time to leave.
So if we are monitoring traffic
and realize that you
really need to leave soon
because the traffic's heavy
and the only way you're going
to arrive on time is if you
take off right now, then we
go ahead and interrupt.
But that's actually the only
case of Google Now doing
interrupted notification.
And all of the others, we were
calling them ambient
notifications-- this notion
of they're just there.
But yeah, I think low priority's
the official name
of the API?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So if you're a developer and
you're figuring out how to do
this, it's actually extremely
easy, luckily.
If you're using the notification
compat class, all
you need to do is just pass in
a priority of, I think is
priority.low or there's a
constant value for it.
And the good thing is that
this actually is only
supported on Jelly
Bean and above.
But if you're on earlier
versions of the platform,
you'll actually see an
interrupted notification.
It's kind of like there's no way
to show a notification in
the expanded state that's not
also in the collapsed state in
earlier versions.
But you will benefit from the
new, better, more correct
behavior on newer devices
without having to do any sort
of backward compatibility
code since it's
already done for you.
NICK BUTCHER: And it's worth
saying that there's other
priorities other than low.
While low is the only one that
will not interrupt the user, I
do believe we use the priority
to order the list of
notifications, right?
So I think if they have
something which is extremely
high priority, or you can
recognize that your
notification just qualified by
the rules but isn't the most
important thing in the user's
world, then you can set
something between low and max.
There's some intermediate
levels.
So you can really hint to the
user so that they find that
list more useful when
it's sorted.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
ALEX FAABORG: And don't just set
it to max because you want
your notifications to be above
all of the other applications.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
I think the one major takeaway
so far is just be mindful of
what the user wants.
Your application--
and I think Adam Powell on the
framework team uses an analogy
really well-- you're a guest
in the user's house.
The user's house, the device,
you're a guest there.
If you're an application that's
installed on their
device, be mindful and
be respectful.
You don't want to barge them
and bombard them with--
ALEX FAABORG: Imagine your
notification is an air horn.
And after the user's suddenly
startled by it, then you have
to back that up with interesting
information that
they care about and
find relevant.
And they say thank you
for sounding that
air horn right then.
NICK BUTCHER: Maybe when you're
a developer you can set
a custom notification ringtone
of an air horn just to test
whether you really think
you are interrupting
at the right time.
ALEX FAABORG: Or we should just
change the API to name it
interrupt the user, and then
people will be more mindful.
ROMAN NURIK: Like
notificationmanager.interrupt
and potentially piss
off the user.
ALEX FAABORG: And it is worth
noting that users can silence
their application from
generating any notifications.
They can also uninstall your
application if it's becoming
really annoying.
So beyond it being the right
thing to do though, are good
reasons to not annoy the user
through notifications.
And it's especially true of
notifications that are trying
to solicit positive reviews
in the store.
I would love to see a study if
that actually results in more
negative reviews online.
I would assume that that could
be a likely scenario.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, we definitely
have some best
practices on when to solicit
views and what not to do.
Especially not to ask
for five-star
reviews, things like that.
But certainly, notifications,
they're really something
that's more timely.
Like, if you want to ask the
user for a review, if there's
any place to put it, it's not
going to be in a notification.
It's probably going to be
somewhere deep within your app
and either a help or somewhere
that they're already exploring
more about your app
and potentially
want to give you feedback.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: And normally
after they've had a good
outcome, I find, as well.
Don't just do it first
launch or whatever.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, they should
have at least had a
chance to use it.
I would say probably you should
never ask for a review.
But if you are going to, at
least do it inside your
application, not while they're
using another application.
I guess another important
thing to note is
correct usage of toast.
So a toast should be a direct
response to a user action.
Usually it's a nice little
confirmation, like message
sent, or item archived,
these types of things.
Where you're hitting a button
and then it's immediately
mirroring back like,
yep, got it.
Do not generate a toast
when your application
doesn't have focus.
ROMAN NURIK: I remember we
talked about this when we were
working on the style
guide a while ago.
And this is one of the big
things, one of your biggest
pet peeves, right--
ALEX FAABORG: It is.
ROMAN NURIK: --when
toasts pop up.
ALEX FAABORG: So I have a
couple different banking
applications installed
on my phone.
I'll be using something else,
and just in the middle of
nowhere I'll get a toast
that says your
banking session has ended.
And I don't even know which
application is responsible.
ROMAN NURIK: Is it
bank A or bank B?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, because
I tend to open
them at the same time.
So I can't even contact them to
be like guys, what's wrong?
So really not helpful to show
a toast out of nowhere.
The reason we have a whole
notification shade, and
notification manager, and all
this is to have that nice
place for your message.
Also, important not to treat
notifications as a
kind of error log.
I know there's some note
applications where it'll
generate notification
that says note was
saved to the cloud.
It's like, great--
ROMAN NURIK: Right, that's
the accepted behavior.
ALEX FAABORG: --I'm
so happy for you.
I was actually off doing
something else.
I just left, but I'm glad you
took care of that and then
told me about it.
So obviously anything that's
just sort of your app managing
itself, I would even say take
this as far as we shouldn't be
notifying people about
software updates.
It's something we're
working on.
Which is Android itself not
following that rule.
But yeah, it should involve
other people, it should be
time sensitive, or it should
be something the user
specifically requested.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
Yeah, very good general
advice.
And just on the top of the
notifications while we're on
it, we also have a design
pattern documented on
developer.android.com/design
that talks about lots of
different situations where you
shouldn't show notifications.
And in addition, we touched
a little bit on health and
things like that.
There's also a pattern
that talks
about health and tutorials.
Not exactly related to
notifications, but still
definitely stuff that
you should read.
ALEX FAABORG: All right, should
we move on to the
design process?
ROMAN NURIK: Let's do it.
ALEX FAABORG: All right,
design workflow.
So we thought this would be
a fun topic to go into.
To sort of talk about some of
the ways that design teams at
Google have their workflow,
which is likely almost the
same as everyone else.
Usually this stuff is
pretty standard.
But talk about the various
artifacts that we create, the
reasons we create them.
What purpose they serve at each
state of the process.
Start running through that.
So the example we use
is Google Now.
I got a chance to be one of the
designers on Google Now.
ROMAN NURIK: Which is very
widely recognized as really,
really awesome design overall.
And a lot of folks have been
looking at that as kind of
inspiration, taking inspiration
from it.
So just personally, I want to
applaud you guys on the design
team for building an
awesome product.
ALEX FAABORG: Well, thank you.
It was a super talented team
that got to work on it.
So we'll give you kind of a
behind the scenes look.
Sort of like movie special
features of what it looks like
before it was awesome as
it was being created.
ROMAN NURIK: I don't know, it
kind of always looked awesome
from what we saw.
ALEX FAABORG: We'll see.
So, here's actually some of
the very first sketches of
Google Now up on a whiteboard.
And as you can see, not great at
drawing perfect rectangles.
But what's great about sketches
is for soliciting
really high level feedback.
So when you show someone just
a bunch of markings on a
whiteboard like this, they're
immediately engaged in the
idea and coming up with
their own ideas
and providing feedback.
They feel like it's appropriate
to provide
feedback at this stage.
Whereas if you show someone this
perfectly rendered, high
fidelity mockup, they'll start
commenting on really minor
details but they won't
be like, actually,
that's a bad idea.
Like, you shouldn't be
doing this at all.
Or have you thought about these
other things that are
slightly related.
So it's important to sort of
scale the fidelity of the
mockups you're creating with
the type of engagement you
want from the people you're
showing them to.
So obviously at this point we
were just trying to generate
ideas on if we had this
proactive software that was
pulling information
for you, what
information would it pull?
That'd be interesting.
So we were kind of going through
various actions you
could have on the cards and
the types of cards.
And actually a lot of the
stuff ended up shipping.
I think everything on this is
actually in product which is
pretty awesome.
ROMAN NURIK: At different
stages, right?
Not everything rolled out in
the very first version.
ALEX FAABORG: No, this was
all in the first version.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, really?
And you've got the flight
notifications?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, we had
flight notifications.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, really?
ALEX FAABORG: We didn't
have boarding passes.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, OK.
ALEX FAABORG: So there's
your very first
sketch of Google Now.
From then, we quickly staffed
up the design team and had
more people working on it.
And here's kind of image of the
sort of war room we had as
we were quickly posting stuff
up on the wall for review.
So again, it's at that
sort of sketch level.
There's some more higher
fidelity things here that are
exploring visual design.
But the purpose here is to go as
broad as possible, instead
of as deep as possible.
Explore as many ideas
as you can.
You're trying to solicit
feedback from
people and be creative.
So not being overly critical
of any ideas to shut
brainstorming down.
But saying oh, that's cool,
but have you tried this?
And I was kind of redirecting
if you're trying to steer
things in a particular
direction.
ROMAN NURIK: Quick question.
At this stage are you thinking
about layout?
In the earlier stage, you were
probably thinking a little bit
about layout, but more about the
functionality, the actual
product itself.
Like, what will the user be
able to get out of this?
What are their benefits?
What are the different
things they can do?
But as this stage, are
you starting to think
about layout yet?
And potentially even I guess
like the pixels themselves?
Probably not, right?
ALEX FAABORG: So I know at
this stage the visual
designers were starting to think
about oh, what if we
were doing automatic layout
based on the content?
And kind of taking the overall
spirit of what the application
was about and applying that to
their space, so that was a
little bit different
than normal.
The layout is obviously--
you can't not have a layout.
It's kind of one of
these mockups.
ROMAN NURIK: I guess what I'm
trying to get at is are you
thinking about all the different
situations for that?
Because as an Android developer,
you have to think
about how does this
look on a tablet?
How does this look in
portrait, landscape?
ALEX FAABORG: No, at this point
we were just purely
doing phones and we figured we'd
deal with tablet later.
And tablet ended up
just being sort of
multiple columns of parts.
In some ways we still
kind of dodged that.
I mean, it's an effective layout
for the device, but it
didn't provide a lot of custom
work for us to do that layout.
So we're still generating
ideas.
Next up would be wire frames.
We were kind of short on time
with Google Now, so we totally
skipped wire frames.
Here's my approximation
of a wire frame.
This is actually more higher
fidelity than you would have.
So then we did full
fidelity mockups.
These were actually created
for a Larry Page review.
And at that point, you're sort
of presenting the full vision
of the application
for feedback.
You're saying we've put a lot
of thought into this.
This is sort of how
we imagined it.
And you're trying to get
feedback on fine details and
also the spirit of the
thing as a whole.
As opposed to feedback
specifically on the finer
things like layout.
ROMAN NURIK: Right.
ALEX FAABORG: So you're giving
them what could potentially be
pixel perfect mocks.
These ended up being very
different from what we
actually shipped.
But they were, at least at the
time, pixel perfect, to really
help them visualize what this
thing's going to be about.
ROMAN NURIK: But I guess maybe
because they were this review
for executives, for somebody
that's higher up, you want to
make sure that they are fully
seeing the actual vision.
Maybe not like sketches.
You don't want to show sketches
to a C-level person,
I'm guessing.
ALEX FAABORG: Well, it always
depends on the executive and
how they're engaged
in the product.
But I think it's often easier
for people to get excited
about something that
looks real.
And also it communicates the
amount of work and thought
that you've put into it when
you dive to full fidelity
mockups at that stage.
And it lets you test
certain boundaries.
Like the contextual header in
Google Now was definitely
something new.
And here we're actually
using photographs.
And we were just sort of
interested what feedback that
was going to generate.
Even at the time we weren't
super comfortable with
photographs.
But we wanted to put
those into the
full fidelity mockups.
Just kind of push that boundary
of what we'd be doing
with Google brand.
So then obviously, you want to
use full fidelity for visual
exploration.
So here we have the full range
of photograph with a filter
applied to it.
And then some extremely block
imagery, very illustrative.
ROMAN NURIK: At the
bottom there?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, at
the bottom here.
With the most simplistic of
bridges, which was actually
pretty ridiculous.
We were just trying to
see the range verses
something more like this.
So we spent a lot of time on
this contextual header.
One of our super talented visual
designers created this
sort of sequence where
here we have really
kind of abstract art.
I loved these.
I actually kind of like this
direction better than what we
ultimately decided on.
ROMAN NURIK: I would have
loved these as well.
ALEX FAABORG: Aren't
these beautiful?
Very, very talented.
Here it was a mixture of time
and day and weather, as
opposed to place.
We ended up focusing on place,
because we felt that people
often had this connection to
where they live and this pride
in their hometown.
So we're kind of [INAUDIBLE]
in that.
Also, when you're traveling it's
really neat to see the
new headers.
So we dropped just the purely
abstract, but I thought these
were just absolutely
beautiful.
Even more abstract, we thought
of those-- that
was going too far.
Here was sort of a mixture of
more abstract with some items
in the background of place.
And then we started exploring
this notion of cities--
San Francisco being shown here,
and one of Seattle.
Here's that same style, sort
of a country town.
ROMAN NURIK: So they were just
playing out different
aesthetics?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, each one
was kind of triggering the
next as we would get this
posted up on the wall.
And talk about what it conveys
and how people are going to
feel as they see it.
So then this brought
us a little bit
closer to where we landed.
It's sort of a little bit
more detailed, but still
illustrative.
And then we're filming
in New York today.
So I thought I'd show one of
the early New York ones.
And these strong shadows which
we see a lot in a lot of
Google's design work.
ROMAN NURIK: The 45
degree angles.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Is that an
experiment with the hollow
style text input box as well?
ALEX FAABORG: Oh yeah, it is.
And we ended up dropping that
because it didn't quite have
the visual hierarchy that
we were looking for.
Especially without controlling
the background,
it was falling out.
But yeah, this was the one
that we settled on as the
direction we really liked.
And then from there it was
iterating on going out and
creating all the cities.
Here we have London.
NICK BUTCHER: Hey.
ALEX FAABORG: New York, there's
San Francisco at all
the different times of day.
ROMAN NURIK: I personally
love the color palettes.
I mean, to me if you were to
drop these into something like
kuler.adobe.com.
Or even Dribbble, they
give you kind of
like a color range.
Or if you upload a photo or
upload a design, they kind of
give you the general
color scheme.
I feel like these, if you were
to import those, they would
result in some of the
best color palettes.
I just personally am
in love with them.
Especially the San
Francisco one.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah,
the ones at night.
I love this New York one at
night with the airplane.
NICK BUTCHER: Do you know how
many permutations of headers
you ended up generating?
ALEX FAABORG: So there's
actually quite a
few more than this.
We're doing them over time
and staging out cities.
We were trying to get
all the cities by
population for a while.
And then we realized we weren't
getting some of the
tech centers, so those
got kind of
accelerated to include those.
So over time you'll see
more and more cities.
We also actually do use some
filters on photographs in
Google Now just so we could have
more coverage at launch.
Because these obviously take
some time to make.
But this was the sort
art style that we--
NICK BUTCHER: I love the
ambition of it as well.
That, yeah, we're going to
provide a localized header for
every major city.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, I know,
which a lot of people were
kind of critical of.
And I was trying to make
the argument, well,
it's a finite set.
NICK BUTCHER: But I think it
conveys something about the
product, right?
This is Google and there's
an element of magic.
And Google boils oceans and does
these crazy big tasks.
And I think it resonates with
Google's image and what we're
trying to do with Now, I
think, very, very well.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, it's also
actually important to talk
about, higher level, why are
we doing all of this?
We wanted to be sure that when
you went into the application
you understood that
it was contextual.
And having the header change
over time made every part,
even the artwork, contextual.
And have it change based
off your location.
So it became this sort of
immediate visual affordance of
oh, these cards really
are live.
They're about what's happening
right now and right here, so
it was able to set that tone.
Whereas Google.com, it's white,
it's kind of about the
infinite possibilities
of finding anything.
Obviously you can still do a
search, but it's also we've
created the search based off
of your current context.
So we felt that that was sort
of helpful to set the user's
expectations of what the
application would do right off
the bat with the header.
Even the motion graphics
design was done
to convey that though.
The notion of the cards dealing
in, where you see them
deal immediately, helps
establish this mental model of
these were just created for
you based on what's
happening right now.
Also, one of the reasons I was
focusing on a card metaphor
was it can kind of help with
expectations of when you're
playing cards, this may or
may not be a good hand.
Thankfully the quality has
been great now-- in the
beginning it wasn't.
ROMAN NURIK: Managing
expectations.
ALEX FAABORG: Managing
expectations, yeah.
Like, oh, I've got good
cards this time.
But it's worth noting that in
addition to all the visual
design I'm showing here, there
was a lot of motion graphics
design that went into
Google Now.
We actually had a dedicated
motion graphics designer who
was working on cards dealing
in, the field expanding.
The microphone radiating and the
circles coming off of the
microphone as an indication of
if you're speaking too loud or
not, which I thought was
really interesting.
So one of the problems with
speech recognition is for some
reason people assume
the accuracy's
not going to be great.
And so they just kind of
naturally start shouting at
the machine.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh yeah,
my parents are--
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah,
I think everyone's
parents, mine as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Pizza
in New York.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
And the problem with that is
then you start blowing out the
microphone.
So actually, the recognitions
are much worse, because you
can't even get a good signal.
So we wanted something to sort
of show nope, too loud.
So it actually hits this outer
radius and turns red if you--
or I believe it does.
That was the design at least.
I just need to go back and
make sure we finish that.
But yeah, to have that kind
of immediate feedback and
have it feel live.
So continuing on with
slides here.
ROMAN NURIK: We'll ask more
about motion graphics then.
ALEX FAABORG: Oh, sure thing.
Well, motion graphics also comes
into play in the-- this
is sort of the most static way
of describing motion graphics,
but here's a flow.
You're basically trying
to visualize
the sequence of steps.
These are useful for knowing
what your key frames are in
terms of I need to animate from
here to here and I have
no idea how to do that.
Which is actually not the best
way of framing it to motion
graphics designers.
ROMAN NURIK: As engineers.
ALEX FAABORG: What sort of
feeling you want to evoke and
what you're trying to
communicate with the graphics.
But flows are also really useful
for just understanding
the temporal complexity
of your application.
Which, it's important
to get it up on the
board and look at it.
And saying is it actually too
difficult to get from this
location to this
other location?
There's too many navigation
steps.
It's going to take the
user too much time.
People often think about
complexity in terms of the
number of objects on screen.
But if you make things simpler
by introducing navigational
steps, you've really just kind
of shifted your complexity
into a different type
of complexity.
So it's really good to look at
the sequences so you can see
temporal complexity.
We also then, sort of the
final stages, Redlines.
Just sort of communicating
specific values, colors,
padding, things like this.
Because you want everything
to be pixel perfect and in
perfect alignment.
This was actually a much earlier
design of Google Now
for the Redline.
But as we were moving onto
engineering, this was the
Redline we used right then.
ROMAN NURIK: This is actually
something that's a very
important tool for designers
to communicate with
developers.
So as a developer, you
generally look it up.
You may look at a pixel perfect
and say OK, I need to
roughly approximate this.
So let me just make this three
dips or four dips.
And that looks about
right, and let me
actually just do this.
So as a designer, if you're
communicating and working with
developers, make sure to give
them these pieces of
information.
And another thing I just want to
add in here is make sure to
note what should stretch, what
should be fixed, what is
responsive.
Almost put in, if it requires
text, like a text description
like this should stay fixed
and so on and so forth.
Make sure to include that.
That's one of the most important
tools, I think, for
communicating between designers
and developers.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Do you have any
similar kinds [INAUDIBLE] for
doing motion?
I don't know how you would
document that you wanted it to
animate in a certain way.
Would you just use the key
frames type snapshots?
Or do you have a similar
technique to Redline's for
saying this should
move like this?
ALEX FAABORG: You
know, we don't.
We do it all with hand
gestures actually.
Which is not nearly as exact
as if we had a Redline.
But often the motion graphics
designer, they're generating
the videos that can then be used
to convert to the final
animations.
So from those you can extract
timing and things like that.
So it would be similar to
instead of Redline, a
developer going into Photoshop
and actually
measuring the senses.
And that you have to view the
properties in Aftereffects.
ROMAN NURIK: And in some cases
if you have the resources, you
could also probably spend some
time to prototype something.
I don't know if we have any
prototype engineers.
But I know that some companies
actually have folks that don't
even build the final
shipping software.
But they will build a prototype
that roughly
approximates the general
behaviors, interactions and
motion, potentially, using the
actual tools you'll be using
to build the app.
Or using things like processing
that JS, or even
HTML JavaScript.
Something that's really easy
and lightweight and easy to
iterate on.
Those tools can be very useful
for communicating that idea.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, and then
communicating late in the process.
And communicating early in the
process, you're just focusing
on how do you want to set the
stage of your application?
How does it immediately
present itself?
What do you want the user's
attention to focus on?
Because much like dinosaurs,
T-Rex's seeing motion, I will
be drawn to anything
that's animating.
So as you're doing the motion
graphics design, it's again
about the user's attention.
What you're notifying them of in
that moment in time of what
on screen you want them
to fixate on.
How you want to draw their
attention to some things.
ROMAN NURIK: That's another
case of don't animate
needlessly.
Don't animate just
for visual flair.
ALEX FAABORG: Right.
Have a purpose.
A story of your animation.
A reason you want users
to focus on something.
Like in Google Now, when you
say Google, it goes into
microphone mode.
So obviously, you might
just say Google
while looking at it.
So the search field stretches
down so you can see what you
acted on as you're going
into that mode.
Obviously when you tap it you
don't need to communicate that
as much because you literally
touched it.
But for the voice input, I
thought that was a really
effective way of telling that
story of the search field has
become the microphone input.
So even though it's not taking
text entry at that point, that
you're still speaking
to this object.
ROMAN NURIK: That's awesome.
ALEX FAABORG: That's sort of the
level of analysis you have
to do in terms of the
motion graphics.
And crafting that story about
how the application behaves.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
So, let's move on to some final
social engineering tips
as you are showing
your mockups.
ALEX FAABORG: So one of the
first things that I thought is
really effective is you want
the feeling to be very
collaborative as you're showing
these to various
engineers and project managers
and marketing people you're
working with.
So one of the easiest things you
can do is show your work
live in the application
used to create it.
So as people are generating
feedback, you're adding notes,
you're making changes.
So it feels like it's
this sort of
fluid, living document.
As opposed to printing it out
and posting it up on the wall
and having everyone just
kind of look at it.
Or even just projecting it, but
it's like a flattened PDF
or something where it feels
more finalized.
ROMAN NURIK: It feels
like progress.
Like actual progress
is being made right
there in that moment.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, exactly.
And not only are you listening
to them, but their input is
directly influencing.
So it's a lot like pair
designing in a way instead of
pair programming.
Or if you do print your work
out, set it flat on the table.
Have both people sitting there
with the pens marking it up so
it feels like it's very
collaborative.
As you're defending reasons
that you did something, or
you're trying not to have the
design be changed in a
particular way.
Don't say oh well,
I'm the designer,
or that's my opinion.
Back it up with specific design
principles with actual
reasons that are irrefutable
on why it
needs to be that way.
ROMAN NURIK: It's tough because
some things are so
very subjective.
Some things are just like, I
have this intuition, I can't
explain it.
But definitely, a big part of
the communication process is
articulating what
you're thinking.
ALEX FAABORG: Often it's
not subjective.
There are actual reasons
why something should
be a certain way--
underlying cognitive science
and design principles.
Or even just existing
user studies.
If you have done a user study
yourself, there are previous
user studies that point to the
same results that you can
anticipate.
So it's very important to make
sure that your take on the
design is dripping in science.
Because if it's just my opinion
versus your opinion,
then you could just continue
debating forever.
Engineers don't debate
oh, well, I think it
should crash more.
Or, I think it should
be slower.
Design does have these
fundamental principles.
Various usability heuristics,
things that we've learned
through years of testing on
how people are going to
behave, what they're
going to focus on.
If they're going to be annoyed
by how many notifications your
application's creating.
ROMAN NURIK: It's probably a
good moment to say that the
design guidelines
that we have on
developer.android.com/design,
a lot of that is taking into
account all these studies that
we've done, and all these
things that you guys have had in
your minds for a while and
putting it down on paper.
Not necessarily saying that
these are the only things that
you should be doing.
But a lot of it is
driven by these
heuristics, as you mentioned.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
Obviously promotes great
guidance, good plug.
I should have said
that as well.
So let's move on to
questions quickly.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And before we move on to
questions, we're running a
little low on time.
But I just wanted to say thanks
for sharing all that
information.
That's a lot of enlightening
stuff.
I definitely learned a lot in
the past 20 or 30 minutes.
All right, so that was a
whopping 30+ minute episode.
Thanks again, Alex,
for joining.
ALEX FAABORG: No problem.
Thanks for having me.
ROMAN NURIK: All right, so we'll
see you guys next time
here on Android Design
in Action.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
ALEX FAABORG: And
Alex Faaborg.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye from
London from Nick
Butcher, special guest.
ROMAN NURIK: All right,
see you guys later.
ALEX FAABORG: See you.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye.
ROMAN NURIK: Adios.